toi il y a un mec qui soit chez toi tu
te fous pas dehors mais Cyril à chaque
fois vous me renvoyer ça
non jamais dans la boutique de quelqu'un
qui vient chez toi pareil dans les
cambriolages mais non mais ça c'est pas
c'est hypothétique tu vis dans la
théorie dans la théorie de la pratique
merci Monsieur bravo il y a le mec de
Mathieu qui n'est pas là
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore merci Monsieur
non mais gilberté
alors à vous je vous réponds avec
plaisir s'il y avait un squatteur chez
moi jamais je ne le jetterai dehors je
ferai appel à la pause
et je réponds au monsieur si jamais
j'accueillais ce qui est sans doute
peut-être le cas des gens qui n'ont pas
de papier je pourrais pas le dire en
public parce qu'on pourrait venir les
chercher pour les déloger mais je sais
que oui je vais vous le dire oui j'ai
accueilli déjà des gens sans papiers
chez moi voilà voilà et ça je le
revendique Cyril ça je le revendique
voilà
quel rapport avec les Français
qui ont travaillé 20 ans pour 2000
balles avec un emprunt 20 ans
vous qui confondez
chez toi
non mais c'est vrai que tu confonds tout
Gilles c'est vous qui sont confondez
tout contre les squatteurs et contre les
loyers impayés dehors des gens qui ne
payent pas leur loyer ils viennent chez
toi ils te disent là on est chez nous
ils ont changé la serrure tu vas faire
quoi tu vas leur donner à manger police
le petit coup de retraité typiquement
moi je les ai en tête encore j'avais
tout bien suivi
en fait plus vite que prévu moi je
parlais de cette
le problème il est simple tu te
rappelles des deux retraites qui ont été
foutus dehors parce que des gens on
squattait chez eux qui se sont retrouvés
à vivre dans une caravane et encore
parce qu'ils avaient quelques économies
et avec un cancer malade exactement donc
c'est ça l'histoire donc eux on veut
c'est pour des gens comme ça voilà
mais toi tu tournes encore autour du pot
et tu dis encore des trucs qui sont
inaudibles excuse-moi parce que moi voir
des gens qui ont passé toute leur vie à
travailler
et qui se trouve avec des gens qui leur
fracassent leur maison parce que quand
il rentre dans un état lamentable si le
rentre deux trois ans quatre ans après
donc ça toi tu fais rien toi si tu
regardes écoute-moi là vraiment tu te
trompes pas mon chéri là comme la jeune
fille qui était venue qui avait perdu sa
maman
c'est toi qui choisis qui recueillir il
n'a rien à faire avec plaisir je
répondais que des mecs viennent chez toi
alors casse la serrure
ils prennent l'adresse ils se font
envoyer du courrier et là c'est terminé
tu en as pour 2 ans c'est fini Cyril si
vous me dites que je dis n'importe quoi
pourquoi alors par rapport à cette loi
est-ce que toutes les associations qui
aident les gens sont contre s'élève et
dit c'est n'importe quoi
parce qu'elles ont lu la loi et qu'on
pourra jeter des familles dehors avec
des enfants à n'importe quel moment
parce que c'est politique c'est juste
aujourd'hui
aux gens qui ont travaillé aujourd'hui
voilà de faire en sorte que tu es dans
la rue c'est très triste SDF personnel
le contraire mais c'est pas aux gens qui
ont travaillé pour certains appartements
au bout de 20 bien sûr ce problème là
[Musique]